اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار يعطيكم من قناه
الجزيره اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قتله
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واعتقل رابعا خلال اشتباك
عند حاجز السره غربي نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
افادت وكاله الانباء السوريه الرسميه بان
ثلاثه عسكريين اصيبوا نتيجه ما قالت انه
عدوان اسرائيلي استهدف مواقع في رفيترطوس
وحما
قال اعلام مجلس السياده بالسودان ان
اجتماعا عقد بين رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حميتي
بمشاركه القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي وقرر الاجتماع تكوين لجنه امنيه
مشتركه من القوات النظاميه وحركات الكفاح
المسلح كما اقر المضي فيما وصف بالترتيبات
المتفق عليها بشان العمليه السياسيه من
جهتها قالت مصادر قوى الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي للجزيره ان قيادات
من قوى الحريه والتغيير ناقشت في اجتماعها
مع البرهان وحميتي الترتيبات الخاصه بورشه
الاصلاح العسكريه
طرح رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي مبادره لاجراء
الانتخابات قبل نهايه العامه وقال ان
بالامكان وضع خريطه طريق للانتخابات بحلول
منتصف يونيو ودعا الى تهيئه الظروف
الامنيه للانتخابات
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه عبد
الحميد الدبيدح بجهود المبعوث الاممي لوضع
خريطه طريق للانتخابات
من جانبه قال رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشري ان هناك اراده سياسيه قويه
لاجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
قبل نهايه العام
اما المبعوث الامريكي الخاص ليبيا فقال
انه يحث الاطراف السياسيه الليبيه على
الاستماع الى ملاحظات المبعوث الاممي
اكد رئيس ميليشيا افاكنرال الروسيه
متر من مبنى اداره مدينه باخموت وقال انه
موجود داخل المدينه وان قوته بحاجه الى
دعم ناري لحمايتها في شمال المدينه
وجنوبها
قال القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه انه اكد خلال اتصال هاتفي مع
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه على
الاحتياجات الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا والمتمثله
في الذخيره وتعزيز قدرات الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني
حتى وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا احدمتري كوليبا
المانيا على الاسراع بتقديم امدادات
الذخيره والبدء في تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين وقال ان الشركات الالمانيه
المصنعه للاسلحه ابلغتها انها جاهزه
لعمليه التسليم لكنها تنتظر توقيع الحكومه
على العقود
صدق مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي على مشروع قانون
تعديل نظام التقاعد بموافقه
195 صوتا مقابل 122
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]